we've all heard that phrase change your
habits change your life right you've
probably heard that but here's my
question for you which habits which
habits matter the most in changing your
life and helping you achieve long-term
success specifically because we know
lots of people who have good habits
right and yet they see other people pass
them by some people have good health
habits and yet they're wiped out by
Wednesday some people have good habits
in their relationships but they can't
get some people to believe in them or
buy from them or support them sometimes
you have good you know habits and
productivity you're organized and you're
staying on track and you're trying to be
focused and yet you see these other
people pass you by like what's the
difference how do you reach heightened
and sustained success over the long term
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to
you've got Michael Jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
things that rich people do that the 99
do not enjoy
the first habit of high performance is
to seek Clarity consistently High
performers are just asking themselves
questions more often about who they want
to be how they want to interact with
other people what's important to focus
on now what would they find meaningful
what emotional qualities they want to
experience in their life and because
they're consistently asking those
questions they're getting better results
than others but you and I both know
sometimes having Clarity is hard what's
the right next decision for you and your
family which if you have two good
opportunities which one do you choose
that's the topic of the chapter on
Clarity in my book the second big habit
for high performers is to generate
energy High performers do have greater
levels of mental focus and stamina
greater positive range of emotions and
greater physical vitality and health but
how do they get that why is it that high
performers don't burn out you'll find
that on the chapter of generating energy
the third habit of high perform
performance is to raise performance
necessity in other words they're getting
themselves in the zone but they're doing
it in a specific way using very specific
sort of mental Ninjutsu and I'm going to
teach you how to do that the fourth
habit of high performance is to increase
productivity something I know you
already know you need to do but we
struggle with you get distracted you
forget what to focus on you feel like
you're not being as effective as you can
you're finishing the week with so many
things that you didn't get done why it's
not because you're lazy it's not because
you're not a hard worker and it's not
because you're not smart it's because
High performers identified their primary
field of interest and then in that
primary field of Interest they found
what is most relevant or different for
them to focus on and then they give 60
percent of their week to that pqo
creating prolific quality output I'll
teach you how to do that in the
productivity chapter of my new book high
performance habits the fifth big habit
is to develop influence how many people
do you know who are passionate who who
practice a lot and prepare a lot and who
persevere but they're not breaking
through because they can't influence
other people to believe in them buy from
them support them invest in them
champion on their way they don't know
how to lead others even if they're a
good individual contributor so they
never rise to the top high performers
figure out how to develop influence and
I break down their practices for doing
that with other people in the chapter on
influence and the last high performance
habit is to demonstrate courage High
performers speak their truth more often
meaning they share what they think feel
need desire dream of want need help with
more than other people they're great
leaders who are living courageous lives
but the question of all this is how well
that's why I wrote this book this is a
moment of time when you can choose to
start focusing on the things that matter
the most so you can achieve sustained
long-term success in your health in your
personal relationships and your business
and your career and I'd be honored to
help you do that rule number two is do
what adds more value with Tom billion so
I'm chasing money for eight and a half
years my Mantra is I want to get rich
that's it there's no rich I want you
rich you promise you're getting rich you
always wanted to be rich when you were
young 100 right so and that didn't that
wasn't a dirty word for me I didn't
understand people who were conflicted
about money I was like it's powerful so
I want to get rich and and I just made
it all about that and so for six and a
half of those years I didn't take days
off even when we would go to London for
Christmas I had like a video camera that
would allow well this is actually
slightly in the future but a great
example I would take a video camera that
would let me watch the production line
at Quest so like that kind of obsessive
like I'm all in yeah back in the
technology company same kind of thing
but I would either be working on the
tech company or trying to start other
companies at night so we talk a lot
about we had like five or six companies
fail all side hustles yeah but it was
like we just kept trying to learn and
figure this out and so growing in that
becoming better understanding marketing
helping Elevate the company company
really rising up to a peer status
watching other people fall away because
they couldn't emotionally hang in the
environment and yeah then they made me I
didn't ask for a raise for five years I
was like I want to be I want to be so
valuable that they feel gross for what
they're paying me yeah and so because I
wanted the equity I didn't want the I
didn't want the salary yeah so I was
like dude I'm in this for the equity you
don't have to worry about me Equity
Equity Equity I just kept it on their
mind like hey you said that was a
possibility I want you to know that
means everything to me and that's why
I'm here and so hit the six and a half
year mark I'm 10 owner in the company
and I'm completely miserable and I've
burned out and I realized that
entrepreneurship had given given given
it was making me stronger bigger faster
and now it's beginning to take away
because I didn't care about the product
I didn't love what we were doing I
wasn't passionate I was just chasing
money and money just wasn't that
interesting at that point on paper we
both know the difference between paper
money and real money right but on paper
I was a multi-millionaire and I went in
and I said guys here's your Equity back
I'm quitting
um I'm not crossing the finish line so I
don't think I should get anything for
this and it actually ended up being like
a really cathartic moment where
we could all say what we've been feeling
which is yet none of us are happy and so
it became well if we're going to keep
doing this if we're going to keep
building businesses because by then it
was very clear to me the struggle is
guaranteed the success is not and so I'm
gonna go do something I love and they
agreed they felt the same so we said
okay well what would we build that we
would love even if we were failing and
so for three very different reasons that
became a nutrition company and for me it
was I grew up in a morbidly obese family
my uncle essentially ate himself to
death when I was 12 years old and it was
scary and sad my mom is morbidly obese
has been my entire life my sister's
morbidly obese has been almost her
entire life my dad at one point was
morbidly obese and then lost weight but
it was like that's just where my family
lives yeah and so I was like they're
going to die far sooner than they need
to and there's this great Mother Teresa
quote nobody will ask for the many but
people will ask for the one and so I
just needed to wake up every day and
think about my mom and my sister and
that was it and I thought I can show up
every day and fight for them it's not
about the money anymore I can fight for
of them and look we a lot of business
Acumen went into this this was not just
we had good intentions and it built a
big business it was we understood
business right I'd now been in business
for eight and a half years grinding it
out building this technology company
which was hard as hell yeah and but now
we were able to marry that and by the
way we took the tech company through the
recession and everything so I mean it
was like I'd taken some knocks so we
really understood business at this point
and so now we were going to start
something predicated entirely on value
creation that was like our Mantra
doesn't matter what's more profitable
matters what adds more value and so we
we literally were saying these things
and we also we didn't actually throw our
hands in a pile of wish we had be a
cooler story but like all but that said
and each of us needs to have fun every
day rule number three love the process
with garyvee I don't think there's
anything wrong with chasing money I just
think that it's usually the quickest way
not to get it
did you consider not going as Rogue as
quitting and going all in did you
consider the the practicality of 6 p.m
to 3 in the morning
no I'm actually just curious there's no
judgment or like I'm only collecting
data because I'm fascinated by the
practicality of it and the fear that I
have when people make I want everybody
to do what you did
if they can do it and my fear is a lot
can't
and that there's a more practical way
than going from zero to a hundred though
some people have to go zero to 100
because if they're half pregnant they'll
never do it it's a completely
interesting Matrix right please
there's a lot of things going on I think
first of all the reason I push so much
on judgment is the biggest fear I have
is that he won't because
you know one of the things I when I look
at them it's interesting I'm like oh
it's good because I wonder how much
she's driving hyping him to get the team
there like you always need you need
optimism and hype to jump like guys
kissing a girl or boy jumping and riding
a bike going in a pool having I become
fascinated with these three events as
children because if you really look at
it it's hype like I remember hyping
buddies in sixth grade be like dude you
can kiss her like hyping like hiding or
when like looking at friends or the hype
I needed to like I was scared she was to
swim or ride a bike or like like hype
like taking a jump
you know at the same token like you know
like sometimes the dude went in for the
kiss and she rejected him and he was
crippled for a decade you know a lot of
people will fail in business and so I'm
unbelievably few 30 years ago had no
choice you had to jump
it's now
depending on the business you choose if
and wellness uh if you open a gym you
physically got to be there you can't but
if you're doing it you know if you're
doing content or information or you
could use content to set up a grand
opening that will win in three years I'm
just it's it it's asked literally just
for data of how you got there
the other thing I'm a very big believer
in is getting people to not feel like
it's a Scarlet Letter if they lose
something nobody talks about at all is
your scenario you jump it fails you
reset and go back and get a job in the
craft that you had because of your
resume
and you restart in four years from now
we have we so America's pretty good at
looking at losses in a positive way
compared to other parts of the world
where it's like a true Scarlet Letter
death forever
but still even here you know people
don't know when to go back from their
jump because they don't want the loss on
the resume
they made the big to do that they're
gonna you're gonna do it now it doesn't
work and what they do is they triple
down into debt
to look good in front of people and what
if it did and you never jumped to find
out oh you're preaching that I want
you've already done that I'm actually
talking about the next part which is
having the options
to know that the game is super long and
that if the business you know when you
go from ice cold when you go from never
having a business to having a business
that's like literally asking me I'm
asking you to right now qualify for
Wimbledon and tennis
it's a lot harder than people think
you're grown you two are grown
I'm not trying to suppress by the way
I'm talking about the practicality of
like options I love that we live in a
world I'm trying to get people to like
really understand how to win this so
much of My Success is completely
predicated on not worrying about all my
losses which means at times you know my
great losses are the things I passed on
maybe I should have done Shark Tank
Maybe
maybe maybe not I don't think I should
have done it not this laid in I think
I'll do my own thing like you know like
but I could but I mean there's a lot of
I mean I didn't invest in Uber when I
could have made 400 million dollars I
mean that's a loss but like all the
things that I've done are things that I
can't see with the outcomes let me tell
you how the Uber thing might have not
been a loss on black and white paper if
I gave Travis the money like I always
was doing at that time I would have made
300 400 million dollars on paper
what if I had invested in Uber and that
led me to giving a speech in India based
on it right and I got hit by a bus and
died like I don't people are just so
like like they don't understand how
light like I'm so happy right now how
could I possibly you know look like you
don't know what life's gonna bring you
right life's complicated and way more
matrixed out and that's why you know I'm
going to start pushing this I said it
for the first time really heavily up
there like the ROI winning in life is
happiness not money people are just so
you know like what I'm most happy about
is if you just love the process
like loving the process like loving the
debates in the kitchen if you get to
like that's what that's what that's what
what about separating that it's great I
believe you I believe you your Vibes
seem good like you know like I think you
know I think that's huge to me it's time
and talent the reason I love hard work
is it's controllable it's hard for me to
be like be more talented
thank you
you know that seems like like when
people are like you push hard you know a
lot of
politically correct you know over
extreme European points of view get mad
at me for Gary you're it's unhealthy you
can't garyvee you can't go to the Grave
with all your money I'm like dude I'm
not talking about money
like maybe you don't like your job as
much like is it wrong to be driven by
money
I don't think I can judge anything I
think the question becomes what the next
thing is
to me it's like to me what
correct correct but I also think that
people confuse the vehicle then so the I
think people don't often get the right
vehicle for their destination
you're right it's a vehicle now my
question is what's your destination and
if you told me it was down the street
I'd tell you to walk not drive a
Lamborghini
so I don't think it's an evil or it's
wrong I think people are confused to why
they try to amass it and what like how
much do you want to make it's arbitrary
what's it based on
like we have to unwind what's been
pushed in our heads
you know 20 50 72 496 what
to me it's to me my big one is can I do
what I want to do every day I was doing
that running the liquor store and I was
making 57 I was happy as I'm no more
happy today than I was at 22. I was
pumped I was on a mission to build a
family business so big so that everybody
on Earth would always say I did the
right thing by my parents and the way
they did to me I don't think there's
anything wrong with chasing money I just
think that it's usually the quickest way
not to get it
I really believe that I really do I
think when I watch people that are
driven by money I see a lot of
unhappiness and failure it's very common
I think I think the question is why
what do you need and do you have a sense
of that because by the way it evolves
what he needed at 24 is different than
what he needs now and him and me and the
you know so it evolves too if we did the
happy meter here it's the people that
are I promise you it's the people that
are doing what they want to be doing
like to me I couldn't explain to you
enough and I have almost empathy for the
cynicism around this statement
it's unbelievable how much I don't like
money I like the game
I love my game
I love the game of building
it's why building you know a legacy is
the best because it's like triple
compounding valuable right I love the
admiration I talk a lot about loving
Rocky six because he goes back to not
having anything
I talk about it a lot it's the same
reason I was selling baseball cards on
Saturday I was selling baseball cards on
Twitter on Saturday for 50 bucks
for a stack of cards I love the game of
growing
you know like to me the best part is the
beginning I love the thrill of the chase
I wake up at six o'clock in the morning
and go garage sailing because there's
nothing like pulling up literally to
this day I can't replicate the high of
going to a garage sale walking into a
yard of junk and finding something for a
dollar that I know I can sell on eBay
for 17 bucks is a bigger happiness High
than closing a six million dollar
account for Vayner and it's not even
close that's what I want for everybody
because that's how they get the 20. I
believe that I really do
so I think the fear I have with
chasing money is its short-term Behavior
and it leads to a lot of like negativity
even for the people that achieve it
that's why optimism or offense works
you know it does but I I do think you
need to be thoughtful about the chasing
the money thing it will lead to a loss
in the macro I believe that also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four focus on
investing with Kevin O'Leary welcome to
the 10x money challenge so Kevin thanks
for taking your time I appreciate it
always good you know always enjoy
chopping it up with you would you rather
be a big earner or small all investor
small investor all day long the way to
look at it I have this thing called know
your nut Grant listen to this and I do
this with really wealthy people too no
you're not you don't need a computer you
don't need a phone you don't need
anything you need a piece of paper and a
pencil listen to this I asked them
just show me all of your income over a
90-day period and on another sheet of
paper what you spend in that 90-day
period I don't want computers right I
just want you to think about how you
make it and even really wealthy people
spend beyond their means the boats the
cars the girls the restaurants all the
stuff that they're burning cash on that
they're not putting back into the market
you got to start thinking about what
happens when you turn 60 and 65 you got
to start putting money away and build
that nut that Nest Egg if you don't know
you're nut you're going to go bankrupt
yeah and Kevin would you rather earned
income or passive income passive income
see because I I hear some people say I
heard one guy say a big social media
guys no such thing as passive income I'm
like I got a million dollars of that
last month I like if it's not real I
don't know how it got to my account
because I didn't trade time for it and I
think the the philosophical way to look
at this is is when you have money
working for you all night long you're
sleeping and it's out there doing its
thing either giving you interest or a
dividend or it's in a capital that is
growing because you're invested in a
business
that was money you had two choices you
could have spent it on something like
you know cars or something and just
pissed it away or you put it to work in
the market which is making you seven
eight percent in perpetuity and
sometimes more first of all do you
believe it's real if you were 25 and
broke whether you live in Canada or
America that you could become a
millionaire in America today yeah I did
that that's exactly what I did I didn't
become a millionaire in Canada I moved
to Boston years ago I didn't want to be
an employee I don't know how to do that
I don't know how to work for people
never could always got fired and so I
started my own business and I worked
like hell and we sold it for 4.2 billion
that was years ago years ago in Boston
and that was my first uh take you know
crack at the Whip and if you want to
call it that and then I retired for
three years went around the world lived
everywhere I got back to work and you
know I've been very fortunate since then
I've had many winners and many losers
but the point is you got to believe in
yourself and you got to focus on
investing you gotta you got to put
Capital to work and let it grow yeah
yeah but let me ask you
yeah in the beginning though like how
important is it for the individual to
make a commitment and not just to a job
doing a good job getting better at their
job but like okay I'm going to create
wealth for myself is that an important
step to make it's the most important
step and the way you do that is you have
the discipline to put aside between 10
and 20 percent of what I don't care if
you make 50 Grand you make 52 500 is the
average income in America you take 10
percent of that each month and you
invest it in the market the stock market
an index I don't care what you buy uh
everybody can save 10 of what they're
making everybody everybody they just
don't have the discipline to do it what
do you like better the real real estate
that I invest in or the stock market did
you that you talk about every day I do
both I have a pretty big real estate
how big is it well it's 31 of the
portfolio right now it's a little less
because I've invested in a bunch of
other stuff too yeah but it's always the
core I own a lot of real estate yeah now
real estate is a wonderful thing but you
know it can cost you money if it's just
land it can cost you money if it's
residential and you're not renting it
out but it's an asset class that has
never let America down ever either by
real estate or you buy stocks you have
to buy assets you got to decide what
you're going to do I prefer assets
because I learned from my mother that
produce some kind of Interest or
dividend I live off the yield and the
dividends I never touch the investment
I don't sell it I've owned these things
for decades and then each month I know
my nut I know exactly what I'm going to
bring in and I have the discipline not
to spend more than I'm bringing in every
month that's my it's it's a very simple
philosophy on life the more you make the
more of a lavish lifestyle you could
have but you never touch the principle
and if you can pay down your debts
because you've got to be debt free by
the time you're 60 years old so you're
saying you live off the dividend or the
passive income not the earned income am
I right you don't
I take that earn income after tax and I
invest it right so you take it earned it
and that's how I grow my nut that's how
I grow my nut yeah so your earned income
is the money you invest
yeah and the passive income is the money
you can buy the the Rolex with
exactly exactly and I know my nut every
month I Mark to Market what I own I see
the cash coming in on the past
Investments I know what I can buy in a
watch I got an expensive wife I got to
take care of her so all of this stuff
we've got a bunch of houses I love real
estate I got to pay for all those two
and maintain them but I know my nut I
never spend more than bringing in I love
the nut the number I like that I strove
for for so long when I was young I told
my dad this and my mother if only I
could figure out a way to put five
million dollars aside
and I worked like hell to get that first
five the rest was real easy after that
yeah do you think I mean yeah do you
think once you have money you can make
money that's the whole point yeah how
critical do you think having that Target
locked in on like even though it was a
fantasy to you you didn't know how to
get there you didn't know the mechanics
but you locked in on that five million
how important was that gotta have that
locked in number because it for you know
what happens is you're thinking about
buying something and you got your nut
you got your number you say to yourself
do I really need this piece of crap and
the answer is no I'm going to put it
towards my target
I mean you're teaching the right
disciplines here I don't care if your
Target's a million bucks I don't care if
it's 500 000 you gotta hit your Target
and the way you do it is you have the
discipline not to spend money on crap
you don't need okay what does a person
do what's the person Deborah McIntyre
Deborah wants to know what does she do
if she's just starting and she's in her
60s so if you're in your 60s you're just
starting the easiest way to do it is
first of all focus on paying off your
debt you really don't want debt I'm
including credit card debt which
sometimes you pay 17 to 21 on you got to
pay that down when you're in your 60s
you got to get rid of that so maybe
you're not going out as much maybe
you're not taking that trip maybe you're
just being frugal
until every test paid and then you start
putting it out there into an exchange
traded fund which is what I like
diversification or if you decide to get
into real estate you buy your first
building and you think it's got to be an
income property though it's got to be an
income property when you're 60. it's got
to be no land no land no speculation no
no speculation you've got to know you've
got as I like to see
cash flow cash flow baby no rule number
five is pay the price with Grant cardo
you may not know this but I have a big
sensitivity towards women because I was
raised I was dependent upon my mother my
mother took care of me and when my my
father passed
I remember walking I'm like this tall
you know I'm like Sabrina's size or
Scarlet size and I would wander into my
mom's bedroom and and I would just stand
over her
and to make sure she was still breathing
because I just lost my dad so I'm just
like am I going to lose my mom too right
so I had this tremendous uh
dependency
on this woman that would Raise Myself my
twin brother and and three other kids
and so I've always had this connection
with women I have two older sisters that
mentored me me and guided me and when I
was lost and struggling and wandering
around they you know one of my sisters
came up to me and said what are you
doing you know and it just like ah
because and I didn't even have an answer
for it
so I went about putting my life together
at 25 and I would not meet Elena for 20
years is that right Elena
20 plus years
and and when I met her by the way
I met a bunch of women along the way
that that I wanted to be my wife but I
wasn't ready and Elena's probably talked
about this about you got to get you
ready
if you're getting junk in your life it's
because you have some junk in your life
and nothing bad happening to you it's
happening because of you
you know it's basically oh wow it's just
a reminder you hate it but like wow God
damn why did that guy do that to me why
did that person do that to me why did
that person rip me off because because
you still have some of that junk in your
life at least I did maybe you don't
maybe bad's just happening to you you're
just a victim
you know well I decided I didn't just
want to be a victim that it was actually
better for me to be in a position to say
oh no I'm making that happen to me
because if I'm a victim oh my God I
can't even change it
so I couldn't find the right woman and
trust me ladies I was trying but but it
was but it was mostly like I was
literally just trying to find this woman
that I could do something with
uh keep in mind I didn't have kids until
I was 51 years old
so so I knew I didn't have kids because
I knew I wasn't ready to be a father I
was married to this business to this
dream that I had and when I met Elena I
you know and I always talk to you guys
about man to get somewhere else
you must leave Where You Are
you will never
you will never
and and I'm gonna tell you this for
everybody in the room you will never
ever experience great change in your
life
unless you're willing to give up
something that you have right now
every single time in my life I have had
to give up something I want it so I'm
not talking about getting rid of the bad
stuff you got to get rid of something
that you actually work for to get
might have been the house it might have
been oh my kids are in the best schools
now it's going to be something painful
for you to get to the next place you
have to give up something that you
worked for really really hard so I sold
my house one day I had this cognition
hey to get what you want you have to
give up what you have
that has been true for me throughout my
entire life I had to leave Lake Charles
Louisiana went to Houston had to leave
Houston once I got comfortable with my
community and my friends had to leave
San Diego had to go to La La is a pit
compared to La Jolla nobody goes from La
Jolla California up to Los Angeles
nobody does that
Kansas City
go to Los Angeles
because you want to be an actor I'm Matt
Elena within five minutes of arriving in
LA
I sold my house I sold my house I didn't
leave it vacant as a backup plan I left
this house okay like I couldn't buy this
house today if I wanted to it was so
like it was a precious little treasure
I had to give that up by the way I had
to give up being the mayor of my little
town everybody knew me it wasn't a
restaurant I couldn't walk into I could
always get a seat I could always get the
best seat I had it right in my hand this
is what I'm telling you guys you have to
be willing to give something up and the
moment you do you better have your
partner on your side
whoever's in your life mom whoever's the
big influence that significant other
person in your life that you're going to
consult that everybody's going to
consult every one of you are going to
hey what do you think should I
you better have that person on your side
in my case I was by myself
so my consultant was like you gonna do
this dog I called my buddy dale dale you
think I should he's like you're
miserable bro you got everything you
want and you're miserable
he's like what do you have to risk
sold the house went to Los Angeles lived
in a hotel I went from a house on the
ocean to living in a hotel the hotel
room was probably like I don't know
maybe the size of the stage so please
please do whatever you got to do this
weekend to figure out whatever you got
to do to get rid of whatever is holding
you back most of which is something you
worked hard to get
okay maybe before the weekend's over you
could write down two or three or four
things you worked really hard to get
that you think you're supposed to keep
you got them already you got it you
already did that you don't have to keep
it
that thing that you're trying to keep
may be keeping you away from the thing
you need to become rule number six is
make a change with Bob Proctor is it
possible
for anyone to go from poverty level to
extremely financially successful
absolutely I think earning money is one
of the simplest things ever learned and
it's one of the most misunderstood
things
wealthy people historically have always
had multiple sources of income they
don't have one
they have many
yeah I was cleaning floors I thought the
answer was work harder because I wonder
I really want to earn some money yeah of
course and I thought it was all
important today my attitude towards
money has changed dramatically
but I thought the answer was get another
office to clean
well I was working so hard I passed out
on the street
I would have been maybe 27 28 I
literally passed out on the street I was
working so hard I came to and there's a
great big cop looking at me
I was laying there it was scary there
was a group of people around me I saw
lights flashing and I saw a guy a couple
of guys in uniform with a stretcher
and it was scary
I had passed out I guess they thought I
had dropped dead
a heck of a time getting away from them
but I did get away they didn't take me
to the hospital I talked about it I got
away and I got thinking
I'm not doing this right
working harder working more hours is not
the way no yeah
in fact
Napoleon Hill wrote that and thinking
Grow Rich he said if you are one of
those people who believe that hard work
and honesty alone will bring riches
Parish of thought it is not true riches
when they come in huge quantities
never come as a result of hard work they
come if they come at all in response to
definite demands
based upon the application of definite
principles and not by chance their life
so you've got to find a demand and fill
it
but you've got to follow Prince definite
principles to do it wow in other words
you've got to be in harmony with the law
you got to give more than you get if
you're trying to get forget it yeah
well
I got by myself and I thought I'm doing
something wrong
I was earning more money
but here I'm passionate it's not this is
not normal
and it's like a little voice in my head
Sid if you can't clean all of them don't
clean any of them
so I got all dressed up
people now accuse me of sleeping in my
suit I got I wouldn't take a suit off I
didn't matter where I was because I knew
the cleaners were tired and I would go
around I got other people cleaning
offices and I knew pretty well where
they'd be
so I dropped around and I bring coffee
and donuts and I would drop in and I
would talk to them both goals and then
grow the next person but I always feel
stressed out because I knew how tired
you get and if I was in working clothes
they'd expect me to help them so they
could finish and go home and she said
but when I had shiny shoes and a suit
and shirt and tied they didn't expect me
to help them clean so I'd run to the
next place and then the next place
and that's when I started to open
offices
um I went from Toronto to Montreal to
Boston to Cleveland to Atlanta to London
England
and you hired cleaners everywhere I went
yeah yeah I had people cleaning what
should someone think about if they're
struggling financially right now and
they feel like they're they've been
struggling for many years and it feels
like they're just surviving week after
week month after month they're not sure
how to get to that kind of sense of
freedom for at least a six-month Runway
or beyond what should they start
thinking about do you know what you've
just described I believe the majority of
people are living that way yeah the
majority now that's rather sad but I
think it's true and it's because we only
have one problem in the whole world and
that's ignorance they're living in
ignorance they don't know that what
they're doing is going to keep them
where they are and they keep doing it
because they don't know how to change
they're overwhelmed with the debt
people are saying I need the money they
haven't got it
they want to take their family on a
vacation they don't have the money to go
so they may borrow it and go anyway now
they got more debt
they have to understand
that they don't have to live that way um
I wrote a book called you're born rich
the truth is you are
most people are just a little short of
money but you are born rich rich and
potential anybody can go to our say go
to Bob proctor.com you can download the
book you were born rich
free it won't cost you a Cent and
chapter two is how much is enough
there's a it's described very well how
to get out of debt
you've got to create a debt repayment
program where it's all done
automatically and then you focus on
Prosperity you've got to have a
financial goal you've got to work toward
it and you've got to understand that you
can earn more than your earning
and wealthy people don't have one source
of income they have more than one
I was earning money all last night while
I was sleeping yeah you can actually
earn more money when you're sleeping
than you can spend when you're awake
yeah you know it sounds like a cute line
but it's true
there's no end to what we can earn
if you are not getting information from
someone who is already wealthy then
you're probably getting information from
the wrong people most people ask their
brother-in-law the guy next door or the
girl they know
how do I earn more hell if they knew
they'd be earning it they don't know and
most people talk to people that don't
know Carlisle put it very well he said
he did not believe in the collective
wisdom of individual ignorance and
that's where most people are getting it
from people who don't know anymore than
themselves
I think you have to go that's why these
seminars are so important today yeah
people have the opportunity to go and
learn most people won't pay to go
I tell people listen you invest in this
it'll probably be the important money to
do it it's probably the last time you'll
ever have to borrow money yeah we I know
our seminars are not raw raw it's not
nothing our seminars teach people a book
themselves it's like when Bill Goff said
if I want to be free I got to be me
I'm thinking I better know who me is I
didn't know who me was I was doing a lot
of things I was doing them right I was
very much but I didn't know who I was
I started to study me and the more I
know me the better I know you you only
have to study yourself you'll know what
everybody because we're all the same
yeah it's our behavior that Stefan our
results that are different
I heard a friend of mine Dean graziosi I
don't know if he coined this or someone
else said it and he said someone else
but he said those that pay and pay
attention
and when you invest in yourself you're
paying attention to you know I never
heard that before but that is the truth
those that pay pay attention but if you
don't pay for it you're not going to pay
as much attention if you pay more you'll
pay more attention an aunt and uncle
who are his poorest Church mice I mean
they just didn't have anything and they
had a whole house full of kids
and I used to drop by their house
periodically I was doing very well and I
was teaching seminar
and I remember it was around Christmas
time and he was rushing around trying to
get credit cards from some big stores so
they could buy presents for the kids
yeah and I said you know something
he said never mind next year will be
different I said you know something next
year is going to be exactly the same as
it is this year because you never change
you
wow I said you should get into the
seminars and learn something I know
something you don't know
well they came to the seminar he got
paid
every two weeks
so that meant three times a year I think
he'd get paid three times maybe four
times a year he get paid three times in
a month
that one pay was extra because they were
budgeted for two pays I made them pay to
come to it something said I made them
pay and I think they thought I should
have clumped him into it
but you know Mark thanked me my Aunt I
don't know how many times did I charge
them she said we wouldn't have kept
coming I didn't even know what you were
talking about I was running seminars it
was seven evenings from seven to ten
Runner over a series of nights years ago
and she said I wouldn't have kept coming
but she said because we paid I came of
course he's right if they pay they pay
attention that is so true and if they
don't they're not going to be you don't
really care when you hear something you
don't like as is not for me to get out
of here I got something better to do
yeah especially in La I want to go to
the beach this is too hard work yeah
it's confronting my ego ah I don't need
this
I'm firmly convinced if a person doesn't
understand a paradigm a paradigm isn't
is nothing but a multitude of habits
they're programmed into your
subconscious mind to control your
behavior
it's got nothing to do with how smart
you are it's got nothing to do with what
your formal education is it's got
nothing to do from which side of the
tracks you come from it has to do with
your Paradigm the Paradigm is a program
in your subconscious mind it's both
genetic and environmental that's
controlling your behavior
everyone that can hear my voice knows
how to do better than they're doing and
they may wonder why don't they do it
it's because you're programmed to do
what you're doing yeah and until you
change the program nothing's going to
change
Paradigm has to be changed I love that
we'll just say are the
if you could
Share three key habits for people that
if they want to continue to grow every
day be more prosperous be more abundant
happier joyful healthier in their life
what are three key things habits every
day not talk about morning routine but
just overall habits every single day
what should people be focusing on
consistently they should study every day
study
they should have a mentor
someone that has already accomplished
what they dream about
they might not even know the person they
could get introduced to them
and
ask them
what are half a dozen things I should do
every day ask them they know most people
are getting information from people who
don't know any more than themselves yeah
and the third one you've definitely got
to have a goal and when you write it
you've already got it intellectually
rule number seven is become a better
Persuader with Ed mylett one of the
questions I get asked the most often is
about what skill do I think is the most
important as an entrepreneur that's a
really difficult question but if I could
go back and you could only give me one
skill to begin with and I had to build
from all of it I can tell you for sure
what it would be for me and that would
be the ability to influence
so it's the ability to persuade people
without that skill set the vast majority
of my wealth does not exist if you can't
persuade people if you can't influence
people to make decisions that are in
their own best interest but that also
grow your business your brand your
company your net worth you can't ever
become successful one thing that
everybody I know that's a leader in
everything they do can do is persuade
people now I watch people do that in all
different types of ways some do it
through intimidation some through it
through Force some do it through humor
some do it through persuasive strategies
transfer of energy you name it but all
leaders can persuade all successful
people can get people to make decisions
in their own best interests that also
get them to participate with their
company it's the number one skill that I
see most people not spending the most
time on is their ability to communicate
their ability to persuade people and
because they're constantly trying to go
to a different course or they think that
somehow their product is good enough or
they get the right sales pitch that
somehow they're going to win but the
fact of the matter is you've got to
become I'm a better Persuader I'm
constantly personally working on that
skill and refining it my ability to
persuade from the stage through the
camera here to make to get you to make
the decisions that are in your own best
interest to persuade you that I can help
you to persuade my children when I'm
negotiating on buying a company or
buying a car or buying a Jet it's my
ability to persuade people to make the
decision that's in their own best
interest to participate with me and so
if I was a quarterback in football it's
my ability to persuade the team to work
the hardest to run the best routes to
get open to give it all they've got head
coaches and football school teachers
their ability to persuade and influence
pastors you name it personal trainer
they've got to persuade people to do the
exercise of it they're the expert so
it's our ability constantly to influence
and persuade people that I think is the
number one skill in life
and so if that's the case what are some
of the keys in doing that so the number
one thing as a business leader that you
should be evaluating is are you
constantly refining constantly getting
better constantly making alterations
constantly being aware of how you can
improve in all of these areas the thing
that happens when I say that to most
people that are average let me tell you
what their response is I already have
that I already got that down I'm already
persuasive I already can do that and
even as I say that to people I hear
people all the time say oh I'm already
good at that let me be very very clear
with you as a friend if you were really
good at that you'd be more wealthy you'd
be happier you'd have a bigger business
you'd have a better family life than you
have so it's your vast overestimation of
your ability about that one skill set
that is probably going to hold you back
more than anything as a friend let me
tell you you're nowhere near as good as
you think you are at that skill and the
fact that you think you're great at it
may be your greatest detriment to moving
forward in your life because you don't
think there's this gap between where you
should be and where you are that'll
cause you to do the work to get there so
I never overestimate my ability to
persuade I always think I can get better
I always think I can grow and I know
there are multiple areas and sectors in
which we persuade people so I might be
really good speaking from the stage but
the question is how am I in front of 30
000 people or 100 people how about
one-on-one how about in my family how
about to a group of three what about in
a board room what about the white collar
people what about the blue collar people
what about in my personal life right
what about getting people just to make
their best effort what about in putting
money somewhere and so there are
thousands of areas of which we persuade
people persuade people to like you
persuade people to laugh at your joke
right so constantly when you buy
something persuade them when you sell
something persuade them persuade your
children so it's your s it's your
overestimation and thinking you're great
at that that constantly holds you back
you're nowhere near as good at that as
you think you are and the fact that you
think it is already an indication you're
not very good at it so you might be
great in one area but not great in the
others and so please don't check the box
and think you're outstanding at that
because if someone who's spoken in front
of millions of people on stages from 60
000 people to six people who's made
millions and hundreds of millions of
dollars in business traveled the world
in multiple different businesses in
athletics I've coached athletes
entertainers politicians business people
one-on-one and I coach in large groups
if I know I need to get better in those
areas I would submit to you that you
probably do as well because I'm not not
as good as I could be or as good as I
should be in almost every area of
persuasion having said that let's take
the business context for a second one
thing I want to challenge you to be as a
leader of your business whether it's
just you're a leader of one which is you
as a salesperson or a leader of 10 as a
team or a company of 25 000 employees is
you must become Evangelical about your
cause and your mission the greatest
business people have an Evangelical
property about them they're evangelizing
all the time they're propagating the
strengths the benefits of their business
of their mission of their cause one of
the great evangelists of all time is
Steve Jobs is a great book written by a
guy named guy Kawasaki many years ago
called selling the dream
and in that book he talks about the way
that Steve Jobs sold the dream of apple
and he literally called him an
evangelist for the cause there's a great
story in that book about Steve Jobs when
he was recruiting he knew he needed to
have a CEO of his company and he wanted
to have the best and at that time there
was a man named Scully who was the head
of Pepsi and jobs was this young kid in
his 20s trying to recruit this executive
who made millions of dollars and he
couldn't get him and he couldn't get him
and he couldn't get him and finally he
gets the voicemail back in those days
the answering machine actually of Scully
and he says listen listen man when
you're tired of selling sugar water to
kids over there at Pepsi and you want to
come change the world freaking call me
back and we'll do it together boom and
he hangs up right he was Evangelical to
cause sugar water and Pepsi changed the
world at Apple right and Scully who's
making millions of dollars the CEO of
one of the most powerful companies in
the world looks to his wife and she says
I think he's right we aren't changing
the world and it was that one cause
oriented Evangelical phone call from
Steve Jobs and it exuded out of his
doors every stage speech he gave every
one-on-one every board meeting when he'd
meet with their software Engineers when
he'd meet with the programmers he was
always Evangelical internally and
externally and built a culture of one of
the greatest movements of all time in
the history of business there's great
lessons there about being Evangelical
the greatest presidential or political
leaders have an Evangelical property
about them the greatest sales people do
the greatest dads the greatest pastors
they're Evangelical aren't they so
you've got to become more of an
evangelist for your cause and your
mission number one number two you have
to sell a big enough dream to your team
to your company to your clients to the
people around you that the dreams of
everybody associated with you can fit
inside the one-year selling it's got to
be big it's got to be bold it's got to
be expanding number three it's got to be
repetitious you can't get tired of
saying the same things over and over and
over again one of the deficiencies of
leaders that are weak is they constantly
think they have to say new things to old
people creating new things to say to old
people the best leaders say old things
to new people they say the same things
over and over again to more and more new
people new teammates new employees new
recruits new clients new speeches new
groups right they say old things to new
people they're repeating over and over
the vision and the cause of their
business of their movement these are
great communicators the next thing all
great communicators understand whether
it's words physiology the look you give
somebody or writing influence is energy
it's the transfer of energy it's getting
you to feel about my company feel about
my mission feel about my product feel
about my cause what I feel they're
conscious of transferring energy to
people because that's what moves people
that's what gets them to act it's not
just the words it's not just your face
it's not just how you're dressed it's an
energy transfer there's a hook by the
way
you can't transfer to me that which
you're not experiencing yourself you
have to physically be experiencing it in
the moment it can't just be the words
you're reading from a sheet you have to
really believe it one of the reasons a
lot of sales people struggle or
recruiters struggle is they just don't
believe enough they don't spend enough
time making the case like a lawyer
litigating to themselves about how
powerful what they do is and the more
and more you really believe you're a
True Believer you can evangelize your
product you can evangelize your message
so invest more time in your own belief
in your research in your knowledge
finding third-party articles magazines
blogs things that reinforce whatever it
is you're doing that feeds your own
belief that way you can give it to me
you can't give it to me if you don't
have it and so they don't spend enough
time spend more time feeding your own
belief and be conscious of the transfer
of energy to another person there's a
great study out right now that I was
just reading about bees and them
deciding which flower to pollinate is
based on the energy the flower puts off
they sense the energy from the flower
and they move towards that one deciding
to pollinate that one well if you want
more people to pollinate your business
pollinate your life if you want to track
the right relationship the right amount
of money the right clients the right
employees the right recruits the right
vendors the right support you got to be
putting off that energy because people
are going to pollinate it somewhere you
want them pollinating with you right and
that's an energy feeling they get from
people the bottom line is people got to
be when they get around you they got to
feel something special about you special
about where you're going special about
your cause special about your mission
that something special is happening
something historic something big a big
old dream in fact one big enough that my
dream can fit inside the one these
people are selling me right and so this
is the key of moving people the number
one skill go all the way back to the
beginning
my number one skill that if I could keep
only one would be this right here the
ability to persuade people in multiple
areas of my life how do I get better at
it transfer energy number one feed your
belief number two number three make sure
that it's repetitious over and over
again say old things to new people right
and you've got to be Evangelical and
sell a big old dream the bottom line is
is that this is a process that never
ends of growing us of growing our
ability to persuade people
if you want to have more money one way
is to uncover the areas where you may be
wasting money and that's why we're
talking about five common ways we throw
money away where exactly did your money
go money is something a lot of us
struggle with check this out in a 2019
employee survey a PWC 71 of Millennials
said their money stress had gone up over
the past year it is stressing me out and
nearly half of all respondents said that
they spent three hours or more every
week thinking about or trying to sort
out their finances and money woes don't
just affect us individually 44 of young
adults said that the money is the number
one stressor in their relationship I
mean the borrow some money and check out
these stats according to Erin Lowry
creator of the broke Millennial Blog the
average Millennial graduated with 37 000
in student debt that's in the states and
some have much more that's enough to buy
a brand new car or put a down payment on
a house maybe you're like yeah don't
remind me Jay hey I get it lots of Us
come from tough places financially and
you might be there now growing up my
family definitely was not what you'd
call wealthy for some of us the hard
times actually help spur us on to
success here's one of the stories that's
really inspired me it's of a young man
who at 14 was evicted with his mother
from their apartment and couldn't afford
a place to live by the time he was 16 he
was arrested multiple times though he
went on to secure a spot to play
American football at a top college in
his junior year he lost his spot and his
NFL career opportunities with it at one
point he found himself with only seven
dollars in his pocket but he kept
working and striving and today Dwayne
The Rock Johnson says that every time he
experiences a big moment of success you
remind himself of those early struggles
when his back was up against the wall
and the only way to go was forward and
that that's why he named his company
seven bucks Productions still even if
you don't have aspirations of becoming a
Mega Movie Star Financial Security is
Within Reach and the place to start is
to stop wasting money now a little
disclaimer first what I'm going to share
with you is for informational purposes
only it is definitely not intended as
formal legal tax investment Financial or
other advice you want to consult a
qualified licensed professional for that
okay so here are those five big areas
where you can stop wasting money and get
yourself on track financially take notes
boys let's start with a super common one
that's really simple Financial expert
Suz Allman says if you're buying a
coffee every day you may be literally
flushing your chance to be a millionaire
down the drain you know because after
the coffee goes through your body okay
never mind you get it anyway Omen says
that if you invested the 100 or more per
month so many of us spend on coffee in a
lost retirement account over 40 years
with compound interest you'd have a
million dollars what that's worth making
your own coffee right actually the
entire category of food and drink is a
big one not only do we spend loads of
money eating out for dinner another big
money waster people often Overlook is
lunch here's a quick quiz how much do
you think the average person spends on
lunch in a year according to Visa is it
a 520 B
1280 and C
2746 if you guys see you're right the
average person spends
2746 dollars per year on lunches now
check this out if instead of buying
lunch you invested that money every
month in a basic savings account over 20
years you'd have I hope you're sitting
down because this is unbelievable you'd
have sixty thousand seven hundred and
sixty dollars and 41 cents I'm gonna sit
down and that's just two basic
compounding interest okay so here's
another big way we raise money buying
new now here's the thing I know for lots
of us I'll be honest myself included how
we look is important we enjoy fashion
but you can continue to have your unique
look and have favorite Brands and still
spend less money on clothing here's a
way to do that I have another friend
who's into designer Brands but would
never pay designer prices her secret is
to shop at consignment stores and now
that there are lots of these stores
online there are tons of items to choose
from and you can even shop by your
favorite Brands the other month I
complimented my friend on a sweater and
she told me she got it for 65 less than
the original price and it came brand new
with the tag still attached plus
shopping Consignment also benefits the
environment because we're recirculating
clothes instead of just making more
stuff Beyond clothing there are loads of
things we tend to buy brand new that we
really don't need to for example if your
iPhone breaks you can actually buy a
refurbished one directly from Apple for
way less money and they come with a
warranty and don't get me started on
cars here's another quiz when you drive
a new car off the lot it literally
immediately loses a certain percentage
of its value what percentage is it a
five percent B 10 or C 30 the answer is
B according to Carfax the second you
drive a new car off the lot it loses at
least 10 percent in value over the first
year it loses about 20 of its value that
means if you spend thirty thousand
dollars on a brand new car within a year
it's worth only twenty four thousand
dollars and the value just keeps going
down instead of needing everything brand
new look at what you can buy used or
borrowed from someone you know and
that's another way we waste money we buy
things immediately we think of it we get
all excited we go online and buy it it's
like when the Apple watch first came out
and I went out and bought one I was so
stoked but no offense to the product I
discovered pretty quickly just in time
to give it back that I didn't actually
need it I ended up returning it
instead of impulse buying virtual
purchases if you say oh I need to buy
that whatever it may be and then go to
Amazon and buy it and then later in the
day I wanted to get some of that other
thing I loved and then going to Amazon
or another store to buy that what
happens when you get your card statement
it all adds up and you're like whoa how
did I spend that much money I don't
remember any of that and that's because
fifteen dollars here and ten dollars
there doesn't seem like much of the time
especially when you're using a credit
card or other digital payment but you
don't see the money you don't feel it
you don't actually have that experience
of giving it away or holding on to it
instead when you think of something you
need and I'm putting need in quotes
because it might not be a real need but
a want put it in your cart and leave it
there or write it down on a list don't
buy it right away then at some specified
time like the end of the week look at
your list all your cards and choose what
it is you really need that will give you
a better idea of what you're actually
spending and what you actually need
versus what you want another way we
waste money is by passing up free money
a court and you're and you're wondering
what are you talking about according to
investment advisors Financial engines
American employees leave roughly 24
billion dollars on the table every year
in unclaimed money by not taking full
advantage of their employer match on
their 401K the typical employee loses
out a 1 336 dollars per year now look if
your boss said hey we'd like to just
give you 1 336 dollars per year you'd be
like yes please right I'm gonna need
that in cash but if you're not
contributing the full percentage that an
employer will match you're basically
saying No thank you so you need to stop
missing out on free money you are what
you consistently do the difference
between where you are right now and
where you want to be is what are you
consistently doing every single day your
habits will determine your ultimate
success one of the reasons why I've had
so much success on YouTube is because I
just keep making videos it's a habit
it's burned into my calendar every week
I am making videos I film I'm here
making this content for you guys now I'm
making more videos more videos more
videos more videos it's consistently
been a part of my routine for over a
decade
if you do something every single week or
more frequent for a decade you're gonna
get some serious results you'd have to
be just absolutely terrible to not get
any results if you are doing something
every single week or more frequently for
a decade most people don't want to put
in the work and I get it and that can be
frustrating it can be slow we want the
instant results
and it's hard to shift the identity your
identity at the beginning
because your habits of not doing
something or your current habits that
you are doing are stronger than the new
habit that you're trying to build
so for me not to make a video would be
so foreign so weird I've made videos
through all sorts of Crisis and and
tragedies and injuries the only time
when I didn't make videos was when my
dog died when my family dog died was on
video day and I just couldn't bring
myself to making the videos so the only
week where I like zero I can't do it
we have to do something else but I've
made videos through vacations I've made
videos through breaking my neck I've
made videos through
everything every tragedy that's happened
every negative every every stress every
frustration I've found a way to make
videos it's so a part of me now not
because I'm superhuman or extra special
just because I put the reputation in
now a new habit that I'm trying to build
is swimming
the pool just opened back up in my place
and I've gone swimming every day for the
past two weeks week and a half I'm going
swimming and it's so it's so fun it's so
freeing I go for my swim I started I
could only do 20 lengths of the pool now
I'm up to 40 and I'm getting better at
it and I feel I just feel so good you
swim you have a shower and then like oh
my body feels amazing right now
but it's still a new habit
right I'm still trying to develop it if
I were to go
and fly to a speaking gig and then come
back I would have to force myself to get
back into oh right swimming swimming
that's what I'm supposed to do in the
morning I gotta go swimming right right
I'd have to set up reminders have to put
it in my calendar
but making videos is so ingrained
because it's lasted so long as I've done
it feels super weird if I if I left
YouTube or sold my Channel or whatever
like oh what do I do now I don't even
know what to do anymore because making
videos has become part of my identity
you too can change your identity you too
can start to develop the habits that
will help take you to accomplishing your
goals I want to give three quick tips
that I think will help you step number
one
is to get really clear on what the Habit
is that you want to develop don't pick
20 different habits that you would want
to do all at once this is where we we
struggle because we take on way too much
like okay that's it I'm done I'm rolling
up my sleeves it's time to change my
life I've had it I've had enough I'm
gonna change everything I'm gonna work
out and I'm gonna I'm gonna eat well and
I'm gonna make content I'm gonna grow my
business I'm gonna find a girlfriend I'm
gonna like whatever the thing is you
come with 20 different habits that
you're gonna do
and guess what you do it tomorrow maybe
and then and then it becomes too
overwhelming too much too much change
all at once
your life just takes over and you end up
back down in the hole where you started
does that happen if you tried to take on
too much at once what is the single most
important habit that you need to start
to build that if you look back in a year
you could say I'm so happy that I built
this one habit because it's helping you
accomplish your goals what is the most
important habit it could be waking up at
a certain time it could be taking care
of your your mind it could be taking
care of your body it could be putting in
a certain amount of work on your
business it could be right in your book
it could be making 100 videos like what
is the one habit
that you want to start to build that if
that one thing happened
your entire life starts to change
it's the Cornerstone habit that you
start doing that because I guarantee you
listen if you start waking up at a
certain time or you start working out
you pick any of them you start doing one
of those things that you're proud of
yourself for doing it other things start
to change in your life around you
because when you feel really proud of
yourself when you feel good about
yourself
other things start to improve too
because if you were say your goal is to
make 100 videos next year okay so every
three days you're making a video
and that's impossible you've never done
that and that sounds crazy and it's way
too big and then you start to do it
you start to actually build the momentum
you start to actually make the content
it's like okay well what else what else
can I do
you know what I want to I want to I want
to start work on health
it's just gonna happen naturally
you want to find a relationship people
will gravitate towards you
because now all of a sudden you're a lot
more confident a lot more proud that's
magnetic energy that people want to be
around
so you picked the one habit that you
want to stay consistent on
and then you start doing that work not
being stressed out about having too many
habits all at once and the whole thing
fails okay step number two you have to
schedule it
you have to put it in your calendar
schedule it it will not just happen
these videos are happening for me right
now
it's in my schedule
I booked time for
I have swimming in my schedule that's
that's even more important in my
calendar so today at five o'clock I'm
gonna go swimming it's in my calendar I
booked it
because otherwise other stuff could come
in maybe I get on a roll on making
videos or maybe somebody messages me and
I have to deal with it something else
will always come up something else will
always come up right stuff always comes
up
and we let that be an excuse for you not
to take action
you block it off you put it in your
calendar show yourself when right which
day of the week are you actually going
to be doing this thing or which time of
day are you actually going to be doing
this thing
and start to teach yourself that this
gets done that when you put less things
in your calendar right put less things
in your calendar and make sure that they
get done because you can put stuff in
you how many times you put stuff on your
calendar or anything get done right does
that happen to you
don't worry about that less things in
your calendar but when you put it in it
gets done again this is building the
identity it's you starting to trust
yourself that when you say something's
gonna happen that it happens and that
just happens one off but it happens
consistently
so you if you've got holidays coming up
or vacation coming up and your goal is
still to do videos or swimming or write
write a page for your book or whatever
it is that is part of your goals
plan your calendar
show yourself what time okay you know
you're traveling tomorrow
okay are you gonna do it before you
travel you're gonna do it while you're
on the plane you're gonna do it when you
land in the city and what's realistic
are you going to be doing a 16-hour
flight with two stopovers and then be
exhausted when you land and that's when
you're gonna do your workout
right like maybe work out in the morning
like just think about your day that's
coming ahead of you and schedule that
thing in
because again when you can stay
consistent on it that's when everything
starts to change
and at number three is get a community
doing something difficult and doing
something brand new is really really
really hard to do by yourself it's not
impossible it's not that you can't do it
but we are we are Community people like
humans are even even me who's
introverted and shy and I don't need a
lot of friends
it's always more fun doing something
with somebody knowing that tonight at
five Nina's going swimming with me
I'm more likely to show up because
Nina's there too
it's gonna be a lot more fun because
Nina's there too get somebody to be an
accountability partner for you join a
Discord group or Facebook group that are
talking about these things so that you
don't feel like you're the only person
going through this because when you have
a down day when you have a bad moment
when you're tired when you had a rough
sleep when you got a terrible news
it's easy to fall right back down to the
habits that you've been consistently
working on the negative have is even
building up over your lifetime instead
of defaulting back to the positive ones
that you want to start to build
the difference between where you are
right now and where you want to be are
the habits you consistently do you are
what you consistently do
you eat one chocolate bar it's fine as
long as you're consistently eating
really well but if you eat really well
only one day and you're eating chocolate
bars every day then guess what's going
to happen to your health
you are what you consistently do and you
can change it
you can change it where you are right
now does not have to be where you are in
one year if you put the habits in place
if you consistently schedule them in
and you get a community to help you so
you're not doing this alone
[Music]
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see my one-on-one interview with
Grant Cardone check their video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there he has no cash and no houses
because Elon knows the money game
he knows the whole thing's a big scam
There's real estate fun I'm doing and
she's like why are you doing this for
people I said I want to help the little
guy